de la verdure et des chants d'oiseaux
pour cadre de travail
bienvenue à la briqueterie il y a trois
ans cette pépinière d'entreprises a
investi cette ancienne briqueterie du
19e siècle situé à feucherolles pour la
petite histoire ce lieu a accueilli le
tournage d'une des dernières scènes des
tontons flingueurs le film culte de
georges lautner en 1963 aujourd'hui dans
ce parc de deux hectares près de 90
locataires sont répartis dans trois
bâtiments
ici vous avez patty canac qui est
parfait moeurs aromatologue et qui
travaillent les huiles essentielles ou
clara sanchez qui a deux casquettes mais
bien distinctes elle est créatrice de
bijoux et en même temps elle est artiste
peintre officiel dont ce nouveau
bâtiment créateurs artistes ou encore
société de bien-être se côtoient il ya
un peu plus d'un an carole martineau a
franchi le pas elle a installé son
atelier de décoration intérieure dans ce
bureau tout équipé c'est vraiment un
moteur que travailler ici parce qu'on
n'est pas seul là on peut se faire quand
même quelques pauses on a déjeuné
ensemble en plus ici on est tous arrivés
au même moment en janvier 2018 dont qui
s'est créé vraiment une synergie y
travailler dans une ambiance conviviale
en argument qui a séduit cette société
de courtage en travaux intermédiaire
pour les particuliers les professionnels
les deux associés ont implanté leur
bureau en novembre dernier
c'est une position qui a ses centrales
dans les yvelines qui est nôtre notre
secteur d'activité
d'intervention on est très près de la
très si on a besoin d'aller à paris
voilà et puis le cadre est très agréable
régulièrement la briqueterie ouvre ses
portes le samedi pour faire découvrir ce
lieu où selon ses locataires
il fait bon travailler